hi I'm Erik Bosse and in the epic game
of Thrones staring contest between the
night king and a tree if you smile you
lose well the night king was grinning
like it's picture day
branch stark in his tree face won the
night swell with a little help from aria
the Battle of Winterfell was such an
insanely crafted 80 minutes of
television so I'm going to do another
in-depth scene-by-scene analysis with
all the interesting details and
connections that you might have
overlooked some of which you can catch
by just brightening the picture quality
others by just drinking and knowing
things let's start by checking in with
the opening credits which include two
new subtle changes first the flipping
blue tiles representing the progress of
the army of the Dead have now arrived
all the way to the Winterfell defenses
but even more interesting laid down in
the Winterfell crypts the flickering
torch lights now snuff out row by row
until the darkness hits us like a wave
this visual for shadows the way the
Dothraki is flaming anoraks gets snuffed
out later the way the darkness hit the
unsullied like a wave and of course the
corpse is buried here resurrecting to
literally no one's surprise the opening
image of the episode is a close-up of
the trembling hands of Samwell Tarly as
he's being armed with dragonglass
daggers this episode keeps coming back
to the close-ups of characters hands
archers hands
Arya's hand the night Kings hand
considering Arya later kills the night
king with a literal sleight of hand this
opening image functions as a setup of a
magic trick telling us where to keep our
eye
similarly the opening spoken word of
this episode is worth noting oh yeah
move your ass Sam
tormund Giantsbane reminded us last
season that in the cold to move is to
survive got to keep moving that's the
secret
walking's good Fighting's better rest
it's directed to move becomes kind of a
game of this episode moving keeps you
safe and warm
whereas paralysis allows the cold to
take you later this episode when Jon
chases the night king outside the castle
he knows he must keep moving or the Dead
will catch him until he has stopped
moving and faced the dead head-on
meanwhile the primary mover of this
episode is Arya pedometer off-the-charts
and her ability to stay in motion led
her to score the ultimate victory also
worth noting that Arya has been on top
of her class by tormund standards as the
one character - in the past 24 hours
walk fight hint back here with Sam the
camera follows his movement at an
unbroken tracking shot through the
Winterfell courtyard if you listen
closely here the sound mixer amplified
Sam's nervous breathing and when Lyanna
Mormont shouts behind him Sam jumps so
worked up that every sudden noise
triggers him this refusal to cut away
from Sam the lack of dialogue here and
the focus on Sam's inner anxiety makes
the viewers feel like we're trudging
around in the snowy mud with this
nervous wreck we are feeling this
tension this episode was directed by the
great miguel zapata nic known for
directing battle sequences like the
battle the bastards in hardhome but I
actually think his finer work was in the
season 6 finale the winds of winter
which opened with a similar visually
driven point of view heavy sequence both
in that episode and in here sapota
accuses close-ups of last-minute
minutiae to show how these characters
actually preparing for their own
funerals the tracking shot hands off to
Tyrion Lannister who unlike Sam wants to
join the others on the front line he
feels useless down in the crypts so like
his sister does while waiting out a
siege down below Tyrion goes for the
wine more wine each new point of view
during this sequence is introduced by a
thunderous drum sound effect
[Music]
the composer is Ramin Djawadi a genius
he does a lot of cool stuff this episode
and here he's using these drums to evoke
an echoing thunderclap a storm on the
horizon to hint at the blizzard that
these soldiers are about to find
themselves in you might also recognize a
bit of a similarity between this pre
battle score in Hans Zimmer's score in
the dark night Jawad II later actually
uses strings that Bend up the scale to
create this uncomfortable distortion
kind of like a plane nosedive makes her
flesh crawl
this also evokes Zimmer's Dark Knight's
score it's the Joker theme used for the
same effect he turns to me why so
serious
sir Brienne of Tarth commands the left
flank and one of her Knights of the Vale
behind her anxiously stirs later when
the white storm in a number of these
Knights break rank and flee as Sir Jorah
faces a wall of darkness a night that is
dark and full of terrors from that night
comes a flicker of hope lady Melisandre
as a red priestess of the Lord of Light
Melisandre resurrected Jon Snow at
Castle black in season six and she plays
a similar game changing world this
episode Jon a Devoe's banished her from
Winterfell after the Battle of bastards
and her role for burning Shireen
Baratheon and we last saw her in
Dragonstone telling Varys that they
would both die in Westeros and saying
that she would go to volantis in the
meantime remember in volantis in season
five Tyrion saw another priestess from
that religion preaching suggesting that
it may be kind of a spiritual hub for
Melisandre to recharger magic for one
last miracle sapota Nix biggest
influences stage in this battle was the
nighttime siege of helms deep in Lourdes
the rings of two towers Melisandre is
last second arrival is the first of many
parallels the elf Hall dear provided
similar last-second backup at Helm's
Deep Helms Deep was fought in heavy rain
Winterfell was fought in heavy snow both
feature desperate torch runs women and
children hiding in the caverns the
terror of the enemy as it climbs over
the battlements and heartbreaking breach
of the fortress walls spilling the fight
into the inner layer as a fight goes
closer
and closer to the heart of this fortress
but despite these aesthetic parallels
appacha tech actually made the Battle of
Winterfell play out a bit differently
from helms deep
a few key ways I'll get to those later
Melisandre greets grey worm with the
common exchange meaning all men must die
all men must serve a greeting we first
heard in context with Arya and Jacques
and gar inside Melisandre gives a long
meaningful look at Arya and all of this
links Melisandre Andrew lures role in
his battle with Arya Stark she turns out
is the Lord of Lights champion here this
episode is called the long night a
literal description of this extended
nighttime battle a battle to prevent
permanent darkness but also the long
night is the name of the legendary
winter 8,000 years prior that lasted a
generation when the White Walkers last
descended upon Westeros and were driven
back in a war for the dawn worshipers of
the Lord alight like Melisandre preached
that a hero named azor Ahai bearing a
flaming sword called light bringer
vanquished the White Walkers and that
azure high would be reborn in another to
repeat history we have speculated that
this prince or princess that was
promised would be John or Daenerys based
on several clues that one of them or
maybe both would fulfill this prophecy
but this episode Aria plays the most
decisive Ozora high in role despite not
really meeting all the cryptic
requirements from the books like being
born beneath the bleeding star and
awakening dragons from stone and being
from the Targaryen bloodline but arias
heroism doesn't mean John and Danny
won't have a role to play in the end
game of this series this episode marks
the end of the conflict with the natural
threat the night king the White Walkers
so the final episodes of Game of Thrones
can redirect on the real conflict of the
series the war for the throne the
existential struggle between light and
dark and these characters reactions to
the external enemy have been the source
of their conflicts between them now
Melisandre is opening the door for them
to refocus on the Iron Throne this
episode actually literalizes this
thematic transition with an overhead
shot of Melisandre entrance to
Winterfell the light streaks across the
muddy snow to create the shape of the
Iron Throne
Melisandre ignites the Dothraki Iraq's
thankfully giving us some light in the
sequence in inspiring their cavalry
charge which ends in
doom for the Dothraki as the tip of the
spear plunges into the darkness the
undead frontline suddenly emerges from
the dark with the Dothraki eyes
redirecting upward to face a giant white
sapota name depicts their decimation
from a distance with their flaming
weapons snuffing out one by one this
image evokes ships on a horizon with
each light extinguishing reflecting
ships sinking the fading of all hope so
why did Melisandre ignite their weapons
just to send these Dothraki to their
deaths why did the Dothraki Leroy
Jenkins with a blind cavalry charge who
thought this would be a good battle
strategy well yes in real world history
medieval cavalry charges were used to
shock and destabilize the enemies and
fill tree lines and I suppose these
flaming weapons inspired the Dothraki to
think they'd be able to see their enemy
clearly enough perhaps this was a
deliberate move by Melisandre a way to
spur Dany to freak out over losing her
beloved Dothraki abandon their battle
plans and actually bring Drogo into the
battle early which would lead to a
sloppier dragon fight outside the castle
walls that left bran less defended
necessitating a different champion to
deliver the death blow
I know it's become eluded but according
to bran every past mistake it's actually
a crucial step toward destiny the army
of the Dead crashes into the unsullied
and northerners like a tsunami but Danny
and Rogan light up the whites with
dragon fire Jawad II scores her rescue
with the House Targaryen theme the
show's way of signaling dragon power
but when it's revealed that John and Ray
gall have joined them jadi mixes the
music with the love theme of the dragon
in the wolf the shows way of signaling
our nephew incest
[Music]
John and Danny target the white Walker
generals along the tree line but the
white Walker generals summon this
massive blizzard this blizzard plunges
them all back in darkness creating a
literal and metaphorical fog of war that
sends these soldiers into a panic many
TV viewers complain that this darkness
made the action a bit too hard to follow
but I think this is mostly an aesthetic
choice a way to disorient the viewer the
way these soldiers feel disoriented
within this fog
raiga land drogon collide another
example of this external natural
conflict kasnian a drama between the
human characters and on the ground the
fog leads to true chaos and one of the
brief moments of lights the dragon
torches a row of lights incinerating the
giant white with it defences crumble
dollar said is the first named character
to die this season and grey worm trips a
bridge to trap his fellow unsullied
troupe something outside of the trench
we saw a grey worm testing this last
episode or eosin Sansa into the crypts
with a dragon glass dagger advising
sticking with the penguin of course a
callback to John's advice to Aria back
in season one when he gave her a needle
sticking with the pointy end in the
godswood bran thanks Theon for defending
him and then says I'm going to gonna go
where oh sorry I can't dance on my lips
i tree bark bran wargs into some nearby
birds to fly up to the night King on
bazarian who's hovering over the
blizzard above Winterfell the night king
reaches his hand out reminding us of the
moment he marked bran with his hand
suggesting that he now might be
activating that homing beacon but the
mark represents and with us and the
night king forms a path to brand by
summoning the whites to lay their bodies
on the fire to form a bridge for the
others to cross over but brand spends
the rest of this episode doing nothing
besides remaining in his warg state and
I guess using his roots to absorb water
from the ground soil but where does
brand go is it really that much fun to
live in those stupid Birds I have a few
theories bran seems to know pieces of
how this destiny needs to play out for
example he was the one who gave Arya
that Valyrian steel dagger last season
in the exact spot that Arya would later
use it to kill the night king saying
wasted on a crippled brand new that Arya
needed to wield this Valyrian steel so
maybe he
through time into the past to make
certain this dagger got where it needed
to go remember this priceless Valyrian
blade was always an odd placement in
these events it was strange that a
low-rent assassin was carrying such a
relic Petyr Baelish actually used that
clue to try to frame Tyrion Lannister
for brans murder attempt but in the back
prior in his evidence in his own murder
trial but it's worth noting that Baelish
never fully confessed to introducing the
dagger into the equation
yes Arya didn't exactly give him a
chance so what if bran was actually the
one to introduce this crucial weapon
into the first part of this whole
historical timeline like Ward back in
time and makes sure Littlefinger gets
his hands on that dagger all to
guarantee it eventually gets to the
Starks and in the hands of Arya Stark
and into the belly of the knight King I
have another theory for where a brand
could have gone before I get to that
thank you to experience for sponsoring
this episode
Experion lets you boost your credit
score's instantly for free by doing what
you're already doing paying your
utilities in your cellphone bill
so if you're like me and you bought a
bunch of unnecessary medieval weaponry
with a credit card to forgot to pay it
off now there's an easy way to get back
up to a credit score that makes you feel
like a grown up a higher credit score
can help you establish credit or get
access to preferred credit options it
used to take months to improve your
credit scores but with Experian boost
you can improve your scores instantly
most people who use boost to see an
increase greater than 10 points up until
now you pay your utility bill on your
cell phone bills and you don't really
get any additional credit for it now you
can boost is safe secure in 100% free no
credit card required Experian boots can
potentially help you establish or
increase your access to credit boost
your FICO score instantly for free boost
is only available at Experian comm slash
new rockstars jump on this ok back to
bran another theory is that brand could
be attempting to warg into the night
king himself like a psychic battle of
the minds
note that bran waited to peace out until
after Theon told him that the trench was
ignited maybe bran briefly tried to tap
into the night King's mind to form this
white bridge which would lure the night
King in to the Winterfell gods what
exactly where brand new area would be
poised to strike wherever you think bran
rolled his eyes - Arya is definitely the
character of this episode each of her
scenes here remind us specifically of
different stages of her character's
growth stick them with the pointy end
reflects her acquisition of needle in
season one in her badassery with her
staff on the Battlement echoes her
combat training in Braavos she and Hound
both save each other in the battle in
different times just as they looked
after each other during their
partnership in season four she creeps
alone in the dark terrified just as she
was as a girl escaping Kings Landing at
season one and of course
Melisandre repeats the famous words of
arias first teacher
Syrio Forel what do you say to the god
of death not today and that is only one
thing we say to a death not today all of
these callbacks with aria are meant to
establish her as a fierce warrior a
worthy champion and the one person in
this battle with the skills to take down
the night king supports makeshifts
aesthetically from the homes deep
nighttime siege imagery to a more
survival horror genre he said that the
less actual fighting you have in a
sequence the better because killing upon
killing desensitizes the audience and
not really feeling anything so now the
episode takes on more horror influences
the white swarm over the walls similar
to the zombies of World War Z and Aria
sneaks around her old home avoiding the
undead like the characters in the house
and George Romero's Night of the Living
Dead one of the whites slowly scrapes a
sword creepily along the floor another
common horror trope the contrast of this
interior setting to the outdoor battle
brings a whole different kind of fear
the vast open darkness and swarms of
undead triggered agoraphobia this
enclosed space triggers claustrophobia
with the walls Aria once saw as her home
now transformed into a death maze
similar to the maze of the Overlook
Hotel in The Shining
when Aria hides beneath the table of the
blood from her forehead wound makes the
loudest drips ever
kerplunk kerplunk shush that blood these
amplified blood drops actually reveal
areas otherwise quietness her footsteps
and movements are quieter than a soft a
drip this is another reminder of her
training from Syrio Forel who taught
aria to be swift as a dear and quiet as
a shadow or as he said on the show quick
as a snake as quiet as
shuttle Aria joins with the hound and
beric Dondarrion who saves Arya
barricading in the passageway as the
white stabbed him similar to the way
Hodor oh dude the door to let brannis
cape during this sacrifice bear holds
his arms out forming a christ pose which
is appropriate considering his Lord of
Light religion is very much the
Westerosi equivalent of monotheistic
religions like Christianity
Melisandre tells area that Barrett's
death was destined to bring Arya to this
moment and Arya recalls the last time
these two women met set up many eyes
forever you're right about that brown
eyes green eyes and blue eyes this is a
callback to Melisandre season 3 promise
I see a darkness in you and in that
darkness eyes staring back at me brown
eyes blue eyes green eyes eyes you'll
shut forever we will meet again
Melisandre was right Arya has killed
people with brown eyes like Meryn Trant
and green eyes like Walder Frey it's
also worth noting Cersei Lannister has
green eyes suggest the Arya might kill
her as well but you know we'll see
Arya's experiences watching lady crane
perform as Cersei and Braavos suggested
that Arya might have some sympathy for
Circe's losses as a mother but the blue
eyes of Melisandre prediction have yet
to be fulfilled which Arya now
interprets to mean the blue eyes of the
night king Melisandre and Arya echo
Serio not today Satan and draw descends
arya off with intensifying battle drums
outside an undead white burst through
the gate of Winterfell attacking young
Lyanna Mormont sapota neck is calling
back his visual from the Battle of the
bastards when the giant 1/1 broke
through these gates Liana bravely stabs
his giant in the eye bringing him down
the visual of this lone blue eye of a
giant calls back the giant from the
march of the army of the Dead that opens
season 7 with the shot focusing on his
blue eye
lianna's badass move should make her
Liana Giantsbane
like tormund there's actually a fan
theory that tormund could actually be
Lyanna Mormont father given his favorite
story that he wants bedded a bear that
bear could have been made Mormont -
Mormont sigil is the bear and mage was
known as the she-bear an aerial dragon
battle wages above and Riggle bites a
chunk out of his Aryans cheek causing
blue flame to bleed out every time he
snaps or bites drogue on knocks the
night king off his arianna temperature
Khorasan him but
work another hint that Oreo was on to
something last week and that skepticism
meaning she might be the one to take him
down dragonfly Oh we'll stop him no John
chases down the night king but the night
king resurrects the dead unsullied
northerners Dothraki violins everybody
who just died out there their eyes flip
open blue just like the ones on the dead
of heart home newly resurrected includes
dollar Asst Edie and Lyanna Mormont from
this point forward every time we see one
of the more recent White's get slashed
the effects team included a detail of
them bleeding a lot more since their
corpses are fresher this latest
resurrection also apparently affects the
dead of the Winterfell Crips soldiers
outside pound on the walls begging to be
let in but then their voices go silent
much like the poor souls trapped outside
the gates at hardhome
you know what they wouldn't be any safer
inside because we see the shocking
resurrection of the corpses seeing these
crypts burst open as a terror
foreshadowed back in the first book when
Jon experienced a nightmare showing this
there are some famous Starks buried down
here Lyanna stark Rickon stark at least
the bones of Ned Stark but none of these
rising corpses look too familiar aside
from this guy who looks a lot like
maester Luwin
that said Lewin probably wouldn't be
buried here the crypts are for stark
family members only and when Lewin died
Winterfell was controlled by the
Greyjoy's after that the Bolton's I
doubt either group would give the old
families Meister an honorable burial
speaking of lewin as Theon battles in
the godswood defending brand it pays off
a throwaway line from Lu and back in
season one when Robb wanted to avenge
bran and Theon backed him up [ __ ] comes
to that you know I'll stand behind you
is there going to be a battle in the
godswood
now Theon is fulfilling that promise to
defend Branton luhan's and old goofy
looking corpse maybe I don't know if
that's it as Sansa and bran face the
darkness jawani scores this final March
with a simple piano melody
[Applause]
these hopeless gourds take half steps
down giving this feeling of one step
forward two steps back reflecting how
these Warriors are sinking deeper and
deeper in despair
[Music]
piano is hardly ever used on Game of
Thrones since it's the more modern
instrument in Jawad II only really one
of these older strings percussion and
choral chance for his musical show the
only exception before this episode was
the winds of winter with the light of
the seven that use a piano signaled the
changing of seasons Circe's ascendancy
to the throne Daenerys has returned to
Westeros jawani chose to use the piano
one more time here for the night Kings
score and like light at a seven the
piano notes lead a wordless march to
death ending in an epic explosive twist
the structuring composition even mirror
the light of the seven
both songs heighten from the bass piano
melody to a more layered theme with
strings
[Music]
and in both songs the flurry of layers
cuts out suddenly to a coda returning
back to the simple piano melody once
more before the final charge
until eventually the finale cuts to
silence as we hold our breaths before
the deathblow comes
[Music]
if you listen closely the moment Aria
drops the dagger from one hand to the
others or Waddy mixed in this eerie
chime this is actually the first notes
of the recurring white Walker theme
music
Aria is returning the night king and all
the white walkers back to ice but how
was aria able to pull this off again
this whole episode has recalled arias
years of training to get to this moment
her steps being quieter than the drops
of blood reminded us of her agility
Swift isset ear why does the shadow and
even recently she snuck up on John in
the same spot he used to be Tula how did
you sneak up on me so it makes sense
that she would be able to slip past
these white Walker generals just fast
enough freezing past their perfectly
conditioned hair proving them to be the
worst Secret Service security ever in
this move that aria uses on the night
king dropping the dagger from one hand
to the other is the exact same move she
pulled on Brienne during their sparring
session last season if that cool move
surprised the best warrior in Westeros
that makes sense it would work on the
night Kings so this means the dagger has
been the most important weapon on this
series it appeared in the second episode
of the series ran armed Aria with it
last season perhaps knowing its future
significance in her hands also last
season an image of this same dagger
showed up in a book that same wall Tarly
read in addition to it being made of a
rare priceless Medal it's actually a
famous relic its dragon bone hilt has
led some to believe that it once
belonged to House Targaryen perhaps even
Aegon the conquerer himself whom George
our Martin hinted might have launched
his whole conquest of Westeros purely to
stop the night gained some sense he saw
what was coming 300 years later and
wanted to unify the Seven Kingdoms to be
better prepared for the threat that he
eventually saw coming from the north so
the destruction of the night King and
the White Walkers redefines the central
conflict of Game of Thrones as less of a
man versus nature existential drama then
a man versus man political drama some
are speculating the night king could
return like through the magic of the
original rear wood tree in the far north
I could see that could be fun but really
it looks as though the HBO series is
leaving all that mythology theory
prophecy for the books maybe for the new
spin-off prequel series and development
and restoring Game of Thrones to the
battle among political factions for the
Iron Throne the episode ends with
another death sir Jorah Mormont aww as
Daenerys hugs his body drogon perhaps
both of them in a group
hug the closing image shows Melisandre
completed her promise to sir Davos said
she would die before the Sun rises
she disrobes takes off her necklace and
collapses in the snow
recalling the moment after she's
resurrected John in season six perhaps
she dies because performing these kind
of Lord of Light miracles takes all the
energy out of her a sacrifice so that
others may succeed this shot of her
death March alone in the snow is a
cinematic image that we've seen before
and all kinds of westerns you may know
it from Mad Max fury road the shot of
furiosa at the end of a rope and
collapsing in the sand it's a kind of
hero walks into the sunset shot except
here it's a march into sunrise the long
night is over the war for the dawn is
won and the war for the throne wages on
do you think Melisandre is death along
with the deaths of other proponents of
this faith like beric Dondarrion Thoris
of mere last season mean the magic and
mythology of the Lord of Light is dead
in Westeros war do miracles like
Melisandre role in the Battle of
Winterfell
Arya's victory and Jon's resurrection
mean the Lord of Light is stronger than
ever and were the clues on the show that
Jon Snow or Daenerys Targaryen would be
revealed as azor Ahai reborn the prince
/ princess that was promised all
manipulations by the red God to position
these two characters in place to open a
path for Arya to be the princess that
was promised comment down below with
your thoughts and theories follow me on
instagram at twitter at ei vas and
subscribe to us on youtube at new rock
stars or to our podcast feeds Westeros
weekly and inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for joining
me and seriously if you're looking for a
vigilant security guard or a bouncer do
not hire the White Walkers
[Music]